I'M LAURA INGRAHAM, THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE," AND WE ARE
DELIGHTED YOU ARE WITH US
TONIGHT.
THE HUNTING OF DONALD TRUMP,
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT
ANGLE.
I REMEMBER WHEN ANTI-TRUMP USED
TO THINK THAT THE DOJ SHOULD
OPERATE INDEPENDENTLY.
>> THIS IS ABUSE OF POWER THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS AGAIN TRYING TO
MANIPULATE SEVERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO SURFACE
POLITICAL INTERESTS.
>> THIS MAY BE THE MOST SERIOUS
FROM INAPPROPRIATE DOJ MEDDLING
SINCE THE FIRING OF COMEY.
>> IS TRUMP USING HIS GOVERNMENT
TO PUNISH HIS FOES AND HELP OUT
HIS FRIENDS?
>> JIM BARR WAS HAPPY, HAPPY, TO
PUT DOJ INTO SERVICE AS
DONALD TRUMP'S NOT JUST
POLITICAL SHIELD, BUT POLITICAL
WEAPON.
>> Laura: OF COURSE HE DID
NOTHING OF THE SORT.
IF THAT WAS ALL A LIE.
BUT WHAT A DIFFERENCE A FEW
YEARS MAKE IN DEMOCRATS VIEWS OF
RIGHT AND WRONG.
NOW BIDENS ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
DOING EXACTLY WHAT THEY ALL
WARNED ABOUT UNDER TRUMP.
WEAPONIZING THE DOJ, DESPITE HIS
DENIAL, IN PERFECT TIMING WITH
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ARTICLE
THAT WAS TEEMING WITH DOJ LEAKS
ABOUT A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
SURROUNDING JANUARY 6TH AND
TRUMP.
GARLAND SAT DOWN WITH NBC TO
STIR THE POT AND DROP MORE
HINTS.
>> WE PURSUE JUSTICE WITHOUT
FEAR OR FAVOR.
WE INTEND TO HOLD EVERYONE,
ANYONE, WHO WAS CRIMINALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE EVENTS
SURROUNDING JANUARY 6TH FOR ANY
ATTEMPT TO INTERFERE WITH THE
LAWFUL TRANSFER OF POWER FROM
ONE ADMINISTRATION TO ANOTHER
ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
WE DON'T PAY ANY ATTENTION TO
OTHER ISSUES WITH RESPECT TO
THAT.
>> Laura: ALL CHOREOGRAPHED TO
DRIVE A NEW CYCLE AND THROW SOME
RED MEAT.
IF THERE'S NO WAY HE ACTUALLY
BELIEVED THAT WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS CONSPIRING
TO OVERTHROW THE GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS 100% LUDICROUS.
IT'S UNSUPPORTED BY TESTIMONY
OFFERED AT THE JANUARY 6TH STAR
CHAMBER.
>> FELT THAT RICHARD NIXON
SHOULD HAVE BEEN CHARGED, I FELT
BILL CLINTON SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CHARGED.
AND THOSE WERE EASY CASES, THOSE
ARE VERY CLEAR, STRAIGHTFORWARD
CRIMES THAT I THINK COULD HAVE
BEEN RESULTED IN RATHER QUICK
CONVICTIONS.
THAT'S NOT THE CURRENT SITUATION
WITH DONALD TRUMP.
>> Laura: WHATEVER YOU VIEWS
ON TRUMP IN 2024, THIS GARLAND
NEWS SHOULD REALLY DISTURB YOU.
BOWING TO THE DEMANDS OF BITING
HIMSELF AND ANTI-TRUMP FORCES IN
CONGRESS, GARLAND IS NO BETTER
THAN THE AVERAGE, I DON'T KNOW,
PROSECUTOR WORKING FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
POLITICAL OPPONENTS ARE
LIMITLESS THEY HUNTED,
PROSECUTED, THEN JAILED BY A
SHAM MINISTRY OF JUSTICE THERE
IN THE MARITIMES DOESN'T PRESS
HIS EXPOSES OF PUTIN'S
VENDETTA-STYLE JUSTICE.
BUT THEY TAKE THE PROPER
JUSTIFICATION FOR GARLAND'S
INVESTIGATION, THEY TAKE IT ALL
AT FACE VALUE.
NO CONCERN ABOUT POTENTIAL
POLITICAL BIAS OR POLITICAL
MOTIVATIONS.
I WONDER WHY.
MAYBE WE SHOULD ASK HUNTER
BIDEN.
A STAGGERING LACK OF CURIOSITY
ABOUT HIS BUSINESS CONDUCT, EVEN
WHEN THE HARD DRIVE, HIS HARD
DRIVE, WAS VERIFIED.
IT'S WORSE THAN JUST A MEDIA
COVER-UP.
SENATOR CHUCK GRASSLEY JUST
WROTE GARLAND AND THE FBI
DIRECTOR CHRIS WRAY ABOUT NEW
WHISTLE-BLOWER INFORMATION THAT
DESCRIBES CONCERNS IN 2020 ABOUT
THE FBI'S RECEIPT AND USE OF
DEROGATORY INFORMATION RELATED
TO HUNTER BIDEN, AND THE FBI'S
FALSE PORTRAYAL OF ACQUIRED
EVIDENCE AS DISINFORMATION.
>> IT'S AS SIMPLE AS OPENING A
CASE AGAINST TRUMP THAT WAS
BASED ON FUZZY LIBERAL NEWSPAPER
REPORTS.
BUT WHEN IT COME TO HUNTER BIDEN
WITH PLENTY OF CONCRETE
INFORMATION, IT WAS SHUT DOWN.
IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE.
>> Laura: THIS INVESTIGATION
OF TRUMP IS A COMPLETE FARCE.
ANY CHARGES THAT STEM FROM THIS
WILL BE SEEN BY HONEST LEGAL
OBSERVERS FOR WHAT THEY ARE.
MORE POLITICAL PERSECUTION, NOT
LEGITIMATE PROSECUTIONS.
REMEMBER WHAT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED
LAST APRIL, COURTESY OF
CONFIDENTIAL SOURCES, THAT BIDEN
WANTED TRUMP PROSECUTED.
HE WAS GROWING TIRED OF HOW HE
DESCRIBED GARLAND ACTING AS A
PONDEROUS JUDGE INSTEAD OF A
PROSECUTOR.
THOSE QUOTES WERE LEAKED FOR A
REASON.
TO INFLUENCE GARLAND.
WELL, IT TOOK A WHILE, BUT
MESSAGE RECEIVED.
ALTHOUGH GARLANDS HEDGED HIS
BETS A LITTLE BIT, NO
PROSECUTION YET.
THEY SEIZED JOHN EASTMAN'S
CELL PHONE AND NOW THEY ARE ON
THE HUNT TO FIND SOMETHING,
ANYTHING, TO HELP DEVELOP SOME
KIND OF CRIMINAL CASE AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT OR CLOSE
CONFIDANTES THAT DON'T REALLY
EXIST.
THIS ALONG WITH THE JANUARY 6TH
COMMITTEE WILL COST THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYERS UNTOLD MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
IT'S GOING TO DRIVE COUNTLESS
HOURS OF BAD PROGRAMMING ON
MSNBC AND IN THE END IT'S GOING
TO ACCOMPLISH NOTHING OTHER THAN
THE FURTHER EROSION OF PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, AND OF COURSE OF
CONGRESS.
>> THEY EDITED EVIDENCE TO TAKE
OUT WHAT MIGHT BE MITIGATING
MATERIAL, EVEN STATEMENTS FROM
TRUMP.
THAT'S NOT HOW YOU BUILD A CASE.
YOU MIGHT BUILD RATINGS BUT IT'S
NOT HOW YOU BUILD A CASE.
HOPEFULLY THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
IS GOING AT THIS MORE IN A
SYSTEMIC, PROFESSIONAL WAY.
BUT WE STILL DON'T SEE THOSE
CRITICAL LINKAGES.
>> Laura: THE DEMOCRATS AND
LIZ CHENEY SIMPLY CANNOT LET GO
OF JANUARY 6TH.
IN THE DOJ, THEY CAN'T EITHER.
THEY CAN'T BRAG ON THE ECONOMY
OR FOREIGN POLICY, SO WHAT ELSE
ARE THEY GOING TO DO?
IN THIS NEW TRAVESTY THAT
JOE MANCHIN, BY THE WAY, AGREE
TO, YOU KNOW, VOTE FOR, IS NOT
GOING TO REDUCE INFLATION, NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BRAG ABOUT
THAT BUT OF COURSE IT'S GOING TO
GROW THE GOVERNMENT.
IN THE END, THE DEMOCRATS'
ENTIRE MESSAGE THIS CAMPAIGN
SEASON REVOLVES AROUND TWO
THINGS.
JANUARY 6TH, AND ABORTION.
WHAT A DEPRESSING MESSAGE.
PLUS, DO YOU REALLY THINK THE
DEMOCRATS ARE CONFIDENT THEY CAN
BEAT TRUMP IF HE IS MENOMINEE IN
2024?
ALTHOUGH, IT'S VERY EARLY, EVEN
AFTER ALL THE JANUARY 6TH HYPE.
TRUMP IS WINNING IN A
HEAD-TO-HEAD MATCHUP AGAINST
BIDEN.
AND AT LEAST FOR NOW HE'S ALSO
AHEAD OF ALL OTHER POTENTIAL
CANDIDATES IN THE 2024 PRIMARY.
>> IF I RENOUNCE MY BELIEFS, IF
I AGREE TO STAY SILENT, IF I
STAYED AT HOME AND JUST TOOK IT
EASY, THE PERSECUTION OF
DONALD TRUMP WOULD STOP
IMMEDIATELY.
IT WOULD STOP.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT I WILL DO.
I CAN'T DO THAT.
I HAVE TO SAVE OUR COUNTRY.
>> Laura: IT'S OBVIOUS TO
ANYONE WHO'S HONEST WITH HIMSELF
THAT OUR GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
PLOTTING TO DESTROY DONALD TRUMP
SINCE THE DAY HE ANNOUNCED HE
WAS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
THEY RELIED ON THE FRAUDULENT
WORK PRODUCT OF CORRUPT
SLEAZEBAGS LIKE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
FILED PHONY PAPERS WITH THE FISA
COURT TO SPY ON HIS CAMPAIGN.
OF COURSE THEY HOUNDED HIM WITH
A NEARLY TWO YEAR LONG MUELLER
INVESTIGATION THAT WAS
ILLEGITIMATE FROM THE OUTSET,
STACKS OF PARTISANS, AND FOUND
NO OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE IN THE
END.
IN THE WORDS OF BILL BARR, IT
WAS A GRAVE INJUSTICE.
AND OF COURSE THE RABID
ANTI-TRUMP FORCES ON HILL, THEY
DRAGGED THE MAN THROUGH TWO
POINTLESS IMPEACHMENTS.
THEY DID NOTHING BUT DISTRACT
THE WHITE HOUSE AND WASTED TIME
AND RESOURCES.
FOR WHAT?
AND NOW THE SAME ANTI-TRUMP
MEDIA FRENZY THAT LED TO SO MUCH
FALSE REPORTING DURING HIS
PRESIDENCY -- OH, THEY ARE
THRILLED ABOUT EVERY LEAK.
>> RIGHT NOW IT'S A MUCH MORE
BROADER NET THAT IS TRYING TO
GATHER EVERYTHING ABOUT TEAM
TRUMP AND PIECE TOGETHER WHAT
POTENTIAL CRIMES MAY HAVE
OCCURRED, INCLUDING, YOU KNOW,
THE MOST SERIOUS ONE, SEDITIOUS
CONSPIRACY TO OBSTRUCT THE
GOVERNMENT PROCEEDING.
>> Laura: A MUCH MORE BROADER
NET.
YES, THAT'S A JOURNALIST.
A BROADER NET.
EVERY FISHING EXPEDITION CASTS
NETS OUT, DON'T THEY?
AND GARLAND IS NO DIFFERENT.
YOU KNOW HOW PATHETIC THIS
ENTIRE INVESTIGATION IS WHEN YOU
REALIZE THAT THE SAME PARTY
THAT'S OKAY WITH LETTING THUGS
WHO ASSAULT POLICE OFFICERS GO
FREE, THEY THINK TRUMP SHOULD BE
CHARGED FOR VIOLENCE COMMITTED
ON JANUARY 6TH.
>> MY GRAND JURY IS ACTIVELY
INVESTIGATING TRUMP'S CRIMINAL
CONDUCT.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
INTERESTED IN TWO DIFFERENT
KINDS OF CRIME.
ONE IS THE VIOLENCE AND BLOOD
THAT WE ASSOCIATE WITH
INSURRECTION DAY.
CRIMES LIKE CONSPIRACY TO
DEFRAUD THE UNITED STATES,
CONSPIRACY TO IMPEDE PROGRESSION
AND RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION'S.
>> Laura: IF NOT EVEN WORTH
RESPONDING TO.
IT'S A NAME.
SO WHY DON'T THESE NINCOMPOOPS
PUNDITS JUST COME OUT AND SAY
THE TRUTH?
IT WOULD BE LIBERATING FOR THEM.
TRUMP SHOULD BE